[Music]
the manufacturer purchases stainless
steel tubes in a range of lengths
diameters and thicknesses
workers select the right starting size
for the specific tube the customer has
ordered
they insert one end of each tube into
this rotary swedger
it shapes the end to a point to enable
it to fit through a die with a smaller
diameter
workers spread lubricant onto a steel
bar
inserted into the other end of the tube
then insert the pointed end through a
draw die
this carriage then grabs the protruding
point
and draws the full length of the tube
through the die and over the steel bar
the die reduces the tube to a smaller
outside diameter while the bar sets the
desired inside diameter
the tube walls thin out and the tube
elongates in the process
finally worker saw the point off the
tube
[Music]
they place several tubes at a time in a
decreasing unit which uses a cleaning
solution to remove all traces of
lubricant the tubes picked up during the
draw process
workers then transfer the tubes to
drying tanks
positioning them at a slight downward
angle
as air blows through the tubes for about
a half hour all of the cleaning solution
either drains or evaporates
to further clean the inside of the tubes
workers insert a felt wad into each one
then squirt in some cleaning solvent
they shoot in compressed air to force
the wad down the tube
as the wide travels the length of the
tube it wipes the inside wall with the
cleaning solvent
[Music]
next workers strap the tubes to a belt
that takes them on a 30-minute trip
through a furnace
the temperature inside is more than 1800
degrees fahrenheit
this intense heat softens the steel
which had hardened as a result of having
been pulled through the draw die earlier
this process is called annealing
and it slightly warps the tubes
so next they pass through a
straightening machine
then the entire cycle repeats until it's
reduced to precisely the diameter and
wall thickness the customer ordered